to help me i need help listen if there
are any chess.com viewers send help
all right well the uh the chat is ready we've
got myth in his normal streaming setup where his
fans have grown to know and love him dardoch
is um sometimes he gets so focused he goes
full fobby full fabiano where all we got is the
forehead and the hairline i'd never go full fobby
is like i stopped my games and then he started
one what is going on whoa he's starting another
game oh did he start another game someone
go aborts okay good the staff reported
somebody shut down that man's ability
to start games there we go i love how we
keep aborted now we started the myth
game okay there we go nice game on
i gotta get another game i gotta get another
game oh yeah that was hilarious all right yep but
he plays the grub now that is we'll
see what he does with white now he's
uh starter's playing black here myth is white
and an open sicilian day okay i'd rather have
it open sicilian than a close sicilian i say
um i don't know where that came with me and
no that was a very wise statement i'm still you
know i'm still considering its implications and a
night or played by sardocian the night or is sort
of a big boy opening it's just not something you
waltz into if you haven't studied openings it's
very theoretical you got to know a lot of stuff
and uh e6 he's playing it professionally
so far right so maybe if i go knight
it'll like divert his attention
here and i have two takes here
for his two so he takes i take take take or if
he doesn't do anything around that and he like
plays around here then i get his knight as well
let's do that let's see how that plays out maybe
that's not the right thing but it does drop the
piece of sardo's reaction he takes that knight
like this he's he's still nervous
but i think he senses that the game
is turned around and now the clock not myths
friend either he's got now down to a minute
unfortunately for white there's no checks
against black skin everything is protected so
just down a piece now white's king
is the one on the shopping block
yeah i see chad saying and agree he's definitely
better than 4.95 the moment some of these things
start coming together myth is going to make i
think bigger leaps than than people will expect
because he's doing so many things right but um
he's kind of almost too defensive minded in some
ways yeah i mean he you know it's easy for us to
say you gotta trust yourself everybody does that
to a degree but um he really as you said danny
you really does zero in on the right things almost
immediately and that is just not something that
anyone takes for granted that's that's some talent
right there super tough but anyway there are some
maybe outside chances there's only a minute for
sarah josh too so this is oh he did take he took
with the bishop if myth gives check and he moves
the king instead of blocking with the bishop we
could have a wild ending like i just predicted
yeah if myth sees that lobster pincer theme and i
think myth is going to give the check on c8 that's
really the only thing he can do here unfortunately
i'm worried that he's just panicking and the
chance is vanishingly small but nonetheless are
dosh stepping up in the critical moment here got
to give him some credit and b4 by myth that's
a really interesting movie he's distracting the
queen from its defense of the bishop oh my gosh
this okay just to show real quick before we listen
in if the queen takes and this check happens
now there's no bishop d8 black would still be
winning but now you have to see this retreating
move otherwise g6 and you get mated on f8 so
let's listen into myth and see what happens here
but this this could still be a wild finish below
a minute now actually good so this gives me what
this gives me free the discover check is gonna be
devastating okay yeah things aren't as
bad as they used to be oh maybe i lied
yep what am i oh wow this track c5
i don't see five right oh we don't block a pawn
move to a white checkmate there's still that
one checkmate okay wait my queen is sucks
oh it all goes downhill dude
it goes south so fast oh no
good game my guy what an intense
game danny that was crazy
good guess what they got another one
if that was tough classy and defeat
yeah this this this was actually the play and
then he goes here i go here mate and one oh
because i go here oh yeah he does like this or
so he does whatever he does here i win oh dude
yeah i didn't see that that's like a that's like
a checkmate in three yeah we could have won damn
well the more you know how impressive myth was
there we saw him at the break taking time to
actually look at that mate pattern that i showed
right with the f6 queen f8 so he's really putting
in the time after his games to learn and get
better and now he's got a grub to deal with
a grub named after henry grubb and uh sometimes
danny i feel like the name of the opening sort of
implies whether it's good or bad and
uh let me just say that the grub is not
on an objective level a good opening
um and henry graub is not a bad player
grub also means like a coffin in in russian so
it kind of represents the kind of opening this is
but he's already in a good position because
myth's last move was not very accurate
okay well he's going to get two pawns this way
listen man if i'm losing a d4 now knight e3 is
actually a really cool move 93 is actually a super
strong move and black would be winning if i'm
losing i'm getting two pawns out of it that's a
really hard he might take on f2 you understand me
if i'm losing i'm getting
two pawns out of that bad boy
oh no oh checking he wants to check
oh he goes for a check yeah but now c3
that puts another piece on fire oh
my lands oh no we're willing no oh
i'm blind damn it the grub strikes again i'm
coming after you kevin oh this game has gone
down the drain fast abort [ __ ] gotta just
abort [ __ ] boys it's not that you know
sardosa doesn't make mistakes it's all about
the consistency though he doesn't blunder too
much and even if he's not playing great he's not
going to shoot himself in the foot too many times
yep make this is playing quickly uh or he's trying
to speed up now because he's down down to four
minutes um instantly broke back to c8 now the grab
pawn is moved to unleash yet another discovered
attack apparently we're doing basic tactical
themes here today unleashing an attack behind it
yep there it goes 10 moves after i thought
it would be played but he doesn't i'm afraid
myth might take that pawn see that's another
thing where you tunnel vision the thing that's
hanging but that's what where i've been impressed
by myth and of course i have to jinx him as always
yeah but he is his logic is impressive that
doesn't take anything away from him yep oh man
help me i need help listen if there are any
chess.com viewers send help send help i'm
down bad i don't know if they have my audio on
but look at my lips i'm down horrendous i am down
bad send backup send the cia send the fbi
send it to men in black i don't send somebody
oh no oh death is beth is among us boys
the ship is sinking all has failed us
this game things aren't looking too hot
all right woman woman and
uh woman and children first
get in the light get in the wraps
get in the wraps take refuge
yeah this is a fitting a fitting uh
way of describing the situation oh
no
not over nice yeah i think
sardo's enough pieces here
that was fun so you know this was close until the
very end and uh andres you played very well in the
final stage of the game to sort of make sure that
your king was safe but it was intense as well we
had no we had no time actually we were both at
two minutes or one and it was so stressful to
actually find a good move and not blunder in this
situation like wow damn at that point in the game
i remember even like at this very phase i was
looking at the time and i was like oh man 30
seconds left i just gotta move something and i
don't have time to like i don't think i was um
i don't think i was like good enough i literally
told myself like i'm not good enough to come up or
think about the right thing at the right time
i just need to move so i don't just lose off
he told me just move the
pc then it will go well so
well speaking of your coach sardosh before we move
on from that obviously uh mr blitzstream himself
kevin bourdee gets credit for the grub this is
uh it it worked out here obviously man crazy
you just play against magnus and himself with
maybe 600 you know under him and he actually beat
him with the grub so i guess if it's good enough
for magnus it's good enough for myth so maybe
you're in good company with the world champion
the grub is that the grub is hard to handle
um but you know seriously man i know you said
yourself chalk it up to inexperience but but
i mean that in a good way that there were a lot
of things we listened in on you a lot and there
were a lot of times your thought process was
like totally on point and i just want to say
that because there were there were moments where
and that game came down to the wire where we were
we were singing your praises and i know that you
know where this event is heading i just uh every
every time we we watch you stream here and play
chess it's you're just getting better every time
man so just want to say that thank you listen paul
champs four and our next match i have a few days
so i'm gonna i'm gonna you know nose to the
grindstone and hopefully you know i could pull
off a few dubs against nico but then you know it
from here and until then i like chess as a game i
really want to stick to it and uh maybe maybe
i'll see you guys next year you know yeah but
it's a it's a lot absolutely the way you're doing
right now for sure great games guys thank you
you